everybody even welcome to today's in CBI
webinar I'm Peter Cooper and today's
webinar is going to be about running the
prokaryotic genome annotation pipeline
on your own data with me today is France
was and we're also have Doug online if
so Doug will be available to answer
technical questions and with that I'm
going to turn this over to France was
he's going to talk about pika hello my
name is josue Steven Eason I am the team
lead for the poor chaotic genome
annotation pipeline a key gap at NCBI
and with me is Douglas Laura who is a
technical lead for the project and we'll
also be able to answer a question that
are more technical than I can answer so
the outline of the talk for today is
first we'll review what the place of
annotation is in the biological analysis
workflow then we'll provide a brief
description of what's an O and P gap is
what the history was and what he
provides we'll spend a good chunk of
time talking providing an example
start-to-finish annotation using key gap
on you and data and then we'll give a
couple tips on how to run P gap on
assemblies that are I would call
preliminary assemblies which means
drafty drafty drafty assemblies and
finally I'll go over a couple of
features that are in the works so just
as a reminder P cap is available on
github and the link is at the bottom
slide so genome annotation is really a
core component of many whole genome
analysis annotation of a whole genome is
the determination of gene location and
gene function in the genome and it's a
precursor of many downstream analysis
including comparative genomics building
phylogenetic trees exploration of
biochemical pathways discovery of
ferren's factor and the list goes on and
on and I will argue that it's also an
important component for the assessment
of assembly quality and we'll get back
to that point so pick up
was started at NCBI about 15 years ago
it is used to annotate almost all refseq
assembly is currently available in
GenBank which is over 170,000 assemblies
from bacteria and archaea and it is also
used for the annotation of many
assemblies that are submitted and that
are engendering proper it is an
automated pipeline that predict the
structure of coding genes as well
non-coding genes and also provides
functional annotation so on the coding
gene side the core components of the
pipeline are protein homology most of
the predictions are made using homology
to existing proteins with the help of
hmm and yeah mostly it remains another
set of protein is called using gene mark
as two plus which is an ab initio gene
finder we predict non-contingent as well
using trna scan our fan and also
homology so that allows prediction of
tRNAs small non-coding RNAs ribosomal
RNAs and we predict CRISPR lucite as
well the functional mutation is done by
a combination of hits two hidden Markov
models to which we have assigned curated
protein names as well as blast rules we
also assigned function using the sparkle
engine we apply conserved domain
architecture with sparkle and as the
last resort we will use homology using
blast B so the typical workflow at the
moment is that a scientist will collect
samples culture of the organism collect
the DNA sequence of genome assemble it
and then submit to NCBI and request that
we run P gap on on the genome so what
we're looking at doing is flipping the
script a little bit and
provide the ability to users to annotate
the genome before they submit and
because if we do that the submission
become optional and why is that a good
thing
because there are many reason why you
may want to run Pig app yourself before
you are ready before before you submit
or you may never want to submit you may
have some proprietary genomes that are
not ready for publication or that will
never be published or you may be at the
beginning of a project where you're
trying to quickly characterize your
starting material and really your strong
material has no place in the archives or
you are trying to QC an assembly
pipeline that you have put together or
you have very large volumes of data and
submitting it to NCBI is just too much
of a burden and finally why would you
use P gap over a different pipeline so
one of the reasons to do that is that if
you see gap it allows a much less noisy
comparison to pick up annotated retic
assemblies because you eliminate the
difference in in annotation pipelines
when you do your comparison so all those
were very good reason that we have been
thinking about for many years and that
that has really prompted requests from
users over the years so finally about
two years ago we started thinking of how
we could put a standalone
pickup pipeline that users could
download and run in their own and the
goals that we had for that pipeline
would be that it is publicly available
that the results conform with P gap
around at NCBI that the results would be
reproducible the pipeline would be
simple to use and you would but it would
produce results that are compliant with
GenBank submission requirements and
finally that pipeline would be easy to
install so in order to do this we
reimplemented p gap as we have it at
ncbi in the common workflow
which are cwl which is an emerging
standard for pipelines so we converted
it from essentially an internal pipeline
language into cwl we went through all
the reference data said that is
necessary to produce data identical to
what the gap would produce NCBI and we
package the minimal set of reference
data necessary and we added some
validation of inputs in order for the
results to meet chamber GenBank
standards so for example we validate the
sequence format we validate the size of
the genome that are provided make sure
that they're within range for the genus
species that is associated with the
fastest sequence and we do run the
sequences through a vector and I adapter
sequence detection so how is paralympic
a package so a peak appearance is really
two things it's a darker image that
contain the pipeline within in CW as I
mentioned so that is the glue between
the application it contains the binaries
and it also contains CW tool which is
currently the reference runner for cwl
in addition to that the PCAT release
includes reference data this is located
on s3 in AWS and that contains custom
blast databases hmm model a taxonomy
database anything that is really needed
for the pipeline to run smoothly in
order to run pig app you need to have a
computer then he set up with Linux
Windows or Mac OS X environment you need
to have python version 3.5 or higher you
need to have installed darker and you
need to have root access this is
important you need a fairly large chunk
of space 100 Gig is what we recommend
keep in mind that the reference data
itself will occupy 41 gig of spray space
and we recommend an 8 core CPU 32 gig
memory machine however you could go much
lower than that
CPU 12 gig minimum is what we have found
so now let's go through an example and
from downloading the pipeline to running
the genome and look at the output so the
first thing that you will need to do is
choose where you want to run key gap and
you can run it locally or you can run it
on a computer format your institution or
you can run it in the cloud that really
doesn't matter so the first thing that
you will do is download the gap both you
want which is a convenient script that
really allows you to do pretty much
everything to download the script you
can use curl as represented in the
command line I posted here on this slide
you can use W get after you add this
creep you have to make sure to make it
executable the next step is to download
the docker image and the reference data
and for that you use that script that
you just downloaded pick up that py with
- - update and it will start downloading
what you need the darker image and the
reference data it will also extract the
rest of the Tarble of reference data and
that will take several minutes and if it
finishes successfully you should have a
message saying download a 100% in the
directory you will notice the reference
data
it's called input and then the name of
the release it will also include some
input data for some example genome so in
particularly microplace 5j italian g37
is a very small genome and using that
the test data for mycoplasma will allow
you to quickly test that your
installation is working correctly so now
let's annotate a Klebsiella pneumoniae
genome so i picked a random genome from
and that is available in assembly at the
moment so what do you need for this how
do you prepare the input so the first
thing that we will prepare here is a
very small text file six lines which is
really
I pointed to two other files the FASTA
file I think you're familiar with it and
another file of metadata both the
generic llamo file so this six line file
and the metadata file are text file in
llamo format the metadata included in
the second file includes the topology of
the sequences so in your multi FASTA
file are the sequences linear or the
circular and includes the genus species
from which the DNA was extracted and
includes the contact info of the person
you're submitting and an author so now
you have downloaded the pipeline and you
have prepared the input so you're ready
to annotate your genome so this is the
command line so que peony UML is a small
llamo file that we prepared and there
are two other parameters here - R - R is
a parameter that will trust me to NCBI
that the execution of the annotation are
started and then when it finishes that
the execution is stopped and the reason
we ask you to please use that partner is
that it allows us to essentially justify
existence it allows us to show our
bosses that people are using our tool
and the second parameter here oh and I
should say all it collects is the start
time the end time as well any random UI
u T so we are not collecting the final
data that you get we're not collecting
the input data that you provide it is
very limited information also in the
command line is the - Oh which after
which you insert the output directory
name where you want to see the data and
it everything goes well you will find
the output in the in the directory that
you specified and you will find after a
couple of hours for a genome
three hours you will get the message
that he got completed successfully so
one tip here is that if you are running
remotely if you use on an SSH connection
we recommend that you screen to Mac's
are no hot in order to not lose your
data if your connection goes away so how
does pickup work what happens when you
run the command line and just show you
so this is this is it so pick up that py
will pick up the very small mo file that
you prepared and it will pick up the
reference data on the docker image and
it will instantiate it docker container
within which think the all execution is
gonna happen so the first thing that it
does to get that py will rearrange the
input data that you provided and insert
the reference data and it will pass
input data to CW our tool which is the
CW runner that takes the pipeline
instructions of what should happen so it
takes the input and the pipeline runs
and distributes the job essentially
runstats after steps so now let's
preview the result the output format
that you get should be familiar to you
if you're familiar with speak up at all
you will get a multi-faceted file
annotated protein you will get the
annotated genomic sequencing yes and at
one format which is a format used for
submission if your desire to submit your
results you will get the annotated
genome in j53 format for using for
loading to genome browsers for example
and you also get the annotated genomic
sequence in GenBank flat file format so
now let's take a look at the outputs in
the GenBank flat file format this is
this is what you would see if you go
into entree and type in any if you look
any annotated genome in entre you would
see it looks personal so the things I
want to point out here is that the input
we provided are reflected in this output
we said that the sequences were linear
you can see that in the output we said
the organ M was Klebsiella pneumoniae
it's here and we said the author was
Peter Cooper and the contacts are also
reflected in the reference a little
below you will see an annotation summary
is something that should be looking
familiar if you have ever looked at
genome that were a Newton we speak at
that summary includes run information
like who is the annotation provider so
your name here should appear or your
name or your consortium name should
appear here their date of the Run which
pipeline was used in this case of course
the gap and which summer vision exactly
you used and below this the annotation
results will appear or a summary of the
results future counts essentially and
what I want to point out here is if you
look at the number of coding genes it's
2,200 2265 coding gene this is the very
low number for tatiana genome what we
expect is more in the range of 55 50 to
56 hundred if you look a lot below you
see there's a very large number of
pseudogenes and the cost for those being
called pseudo gene is as is that there
are frame shifted so that points out
that sort of raises a red flag on the
assembly itself and potentially
indicates that there's a lot of indents
in the assembly and this is really an
important reason why it's great for you
to run p gap before you submit and
really what you should do instead of
submitting immediately you should review
the results and submit them only in
their high quality if you don't find the
results to be very satisfying that gives
you an opportunity to go back to your
sequence or to the assembly and fix what
you think is I have gone wrong so we
hope that by putting P gap in in your
hands you that cycle of annotating with
Ewing and going back to the message will
be
much shorter so side note on how you can
1p gap on draft assembly so at the
beginning of the of the talk I explained
that we in addition to pig app we
validate the sequences upfront well we
are the opportunity to ignore this
validation so for example the genome
size check you could you know maybe
you're just annotated plasma baby you're
just interested in a portion of the
genomes or maybe you don't know why but
your genome doesn't fit this size
expected for the genus species well you
can ignore that with that ignored - all
- error flag it will also ignores
invalid sequence due to vector and
adapter sequence those could be cleaned
up later if you wish and you will also
ignore stretches of ends at the end of
sequences that flag also allows you to
run on undefined species so you may have
an idea of the genus but notice issues
so and this is convenient for to get a
sense of the assembly quality early in
your workflow but you should be aware
that the result that a produce may not
comply with GenBank quality criteria so
if you intend to submit the results this
is not a fact that you want to use so
moving on to what is coming soon so
there's a couple things that we've been
hard at work with first is support
singularity as an alternative to docker
the advantage of security over docker is
that it doesn't require root access so
the way things are going to work is that
will still package the image in docker
however when it comes to running the
pipeline the container will be
instantiating the container instantiated
will be a singularity container that
doesn't require root we are also
planning to add a taxonomic verification
module which is the taxonomic
verification is done by calculation of
the average nucleotide identity
which is a tool that GenBank uses when
evaluating the quality of assemblies are
submitted so that allows you to sort of
get one step ahead and and anticipate
what sort of feedback you will get from
GenBank and finally P gap currently
requires network access and we're
working on lifting requirements for this
so that for people working by your
defense who have some very sensitive
data and don't want the pipeline to
access the Internet and any point they
can still want again so more information
is available on github
this is our site again you can find the
peak appearances there there's
documentation on installation there's
Isaac use and very important there's a
form for you to report any issues and we
really welcome any comment that you have
whether it's feature request whether you
have problems you know we we are really
committed to make your life easier so
don't hesitate you can also look at open
past issues just to see whether other
people have run into the same problem
that you have finally I want to
acknowledge all the member of the team
I said by Dresden and Douglas Lara have
done the bulk of the work
slava chat brennan Ratko Lavina and yah
moses I've also helped Daniel Soren is a
project manager and Ben Busby and Luis
Guerra
I have helped early on on getting the
problem the project started and fine
team is sounding pretty I've giving us
their support in addition to Eugene
Yushchenko I also want to acknowledge
SIF Turner who was one of the user who
really asked us was really having a
pickup in his hands and I want to thank
you for your attention and now I like
chef question it's the time to ask
thanks Prince was a couple of questions
came in and they sort of relate to some
other topics too so someone asked about
you know how to create a text file
and they mentioned a bunch of different
types of text editors but reading the
main point is it just needs to be plain
text one of the questions that that's
where it comes from that is what
platforms can you run this on so can you
run this on Windows and Mac and Linux
all those things or is it only available
for certain ones it can run on any
operating system we have most of my
experiences in Linux but there is there
is possibility to run it on Windows and
Mac OS X as well so this is this is the
operating system when I'm talking about
the operating system for the computer
you should know that the container
itself runs in Linux okay thanks for
instance was um also you mentioned the
average nucleotide identity and someone
asked can you skip that step and Douglas
actually I answered this into the
questions pod that they and I will be
optional so you can choose to run to get
all your anti only or both and so
another question that's sort of related
to this idea is is there any
consideration of lifting the
requirements so you mentioned for
example that you could have an unknown
species but you could have a genus you
need to know the geniuses are a way to
go with like if you don't know what it
is yes you need to know the genus the
reason for this is that the genus
influences a set of protein that we
aligned to genome and especially the it
really influences the weight that we
gave to certain proteins so we will up
weight the proteins that are references
that are called reference protein that
are annotated on a reference genome for
the genus so if you change the genus
then we will up weight potentially
proteins that are completely unrelated
to the genome that your annotated so
this is really the idea for requiring at
a minimum the genus and so wouldn't that
be a way that they and I could come into
play if you had something like that and
you didn't know the genus than at least
that would give you could even give you
the species possibly but probably would
give you a genus level
right so ni is not yet in the pipeline
but this is something that we could
envision is that you first run ni to
determine what's what's in your sample
essentially what you've sequence and
then so it would be a two step process
first run in AI alone and then when you
get an idea of what your species likely
is you would then run P gap with the
proper species that ni determined okay
thanks okay thanks everybody I don't see
any more questions right now if you have
additional questions please feel free to
write to us at info at NCBI NLM nih.gov
if you have questions about the webinar
program in general you can write to us
at webinars at the same domain name NCBI
LM H gov and on this slide there are
some links to some general educational
materials that we have on our website ok
so let's go ahead and conclude the
webinar thanks everybody for coming and
I'll go ahead and sign off thank you